the younger generation runs on Disney
which is why it's so important for these
movies to be filled with inspiring plots
it's not easy
nevertheless there have been times when
Disney flew too close to the Sun and got
burnt watch until the end to find out
which Disney movie got cancelled due to
being loaded with unforgiving and
extremely mature jokes Don Quixote it's
no secret that Disney loves a challenge
but you know what they don't love a
scandal so after trying to turn the
novel Don Quixote into a cinematic
experience for the fourth time
Disney chose to put this project to rest
for good so why didn't this novel ever
make it to the big screen
well it's themes were deemed too adult
for Disney to explore and since some
parents would opt against letting their
kids watch the film it was just too
risky to pursue the ancient fairy tale
was written by Miguel de Cervantes in
1605 it came in two parts and the second
one was written in 1615 although
fictional this book had a certain amount
of truth to it which shed light on
events that occurred in the 14th century
for this reason many believe Don Quixote
to be a real person the book introduces
us to Alonso Quijano who is a 50 year
old man who reads too much and sleeps
too little he's known for his dry and
risky humor and is often reprimanded for
reading too much Alonso is so fascinated
with the stories he reads that he
embarks on a quest to become like his
heroes he changes his name to Don
Quixote pretends to be in a relationship
with a neighboring farm girl and
proceeds to live out his delusions
although this movie would have been
interesting it's riddled with
inappropriate themes some of which
border on mental health and underage
relationships so by default it was
simply too risky for Disney to take on
Reynard
for decades Disney struggled to make
light of the dark and twisted storylines
that encouraged them to create movies
like Chanticleer and Reynard the movie
Reynard was based on an old folktale
which revolved around a conniving Fox
who loved to play tricks on people at
first Disney tried to fuse both movies
together to allow their character
Reynard to see the
to eight however the merging fell flat
and both projects were later dropped due
to their characters being a little too
violent these movies were in development
throughout the 40s and 50s however Walt
Disney himself would soon pull the plug
he chose to scrap these projects due to
reynard's unpredictable nature you see
although Reynard was funny and enjoyed
playing pranks on those around him his
victims usually wound up severely hurt
or worse
gone for good although they want to
paint the character in a different light
the old folktale reminded them that
Raynor just wasn't a good protagonist so
the movie was cancelled due to its dark
roots luckily their work wasn't all for
naught as Reynard taped the path for the
beloved character Robin Hood so Disney
animators and writers soon set their
sights on creating a Fox themed
character who had a pesky nature but a
wholesome heart if you thought Reynard
was controversial wait until you hear
about the movie wild life the reason why
this movie was canceled is so shocking
you might have to catch your job before
it hits the ground the Seven Dwarfs Walt
Disney Studios released their very first
feature-length animated film in 1938
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs was a
major hit which is why Disney planned on
continuing the franchise decades later
in the early 2000s DisneyToon Studios
sought to pick up where their founder
left off
they began animating a prequel titled
the Seven Dwarfs this movie was meant to
give this doors advance Tori and explain
how they came to live together in
harmony with this stellar idea in mind
director Mike disa and screenwriter
Evansville Ito palace joined forces and
began tackling the project although the
movie would have primarily focused on
the Dorf it would also explain how the
Evil Queen managed to take Snow White's
Father's throne their idea was met by a
positive response and the duo was given
creative freedom over the project
oddly enough the film was later
cancelled in 2006 so why did Disney drop
such a promising project well it turns
out that the movie was simply too dark
and traumatizing for its target audience
according to Mike DISA DisneyToon
management soon changed their tune and
began tweaking their original idea they
wanted the movie to focus on how dopey
lost his voice however the reason behind
Dobies muteness was set to be the result
witnessing his mother's tragic passing
now if that isn't traumatizing we don't
know what is
since dizzy toon was fixated on this
unfortunate plot Mike D Sassoon dropped
out of the project citing creative
differences
soon after in 2006 Disney purchased
Pixar an existing projects were put
under the scope so for obvious reasons
the newly appointed chief creative
officer John Lasseter chose to pull the
plug on the Seven Dwarves more they say
that when one door closes another opens
and whoever they are they sure do make a
lot of sense
take Disney's Moana for instance if it
hadn't been for mort's cancellation we
might not have seen the Polynesian
princess come to life around 2010 Disney
set their sights on a movie titled Mort
which translates to death in French but
this is no mere coincidence as the grim
reaper was set to be a starring role for
obvious reasons this rubb Disney the
wrong way
Disney higher-ups were skeptical about
releasing a kid's movie that held such a
terminal theme however this wasn't the
only reason the movie was pulled as
Disney had issues acquiring the rights
to Terry Pratchett's Discworld novel
which the movie was modeled after if the
film had been published we would have
met a young man named Mort who would be
chosen to become dets apprentice we
would see him get trained by the Grim
Reaper and take on his first solo
assignment however Mort would soon fall
in love with a princess whose life he
was meant to collect and despite his
training he would save her from her fate
which would threaten the balance of the
world since this animated film was set
in a dark and terrifying landscape there
was no way of knowing if the movie would
be a hit or a miss so the project was
soon cancelled the movies directors Ron
Clements and John Musker
went on to create Moana which quickly
became a fan favorite and although we
love Moana we have to admit that morte
sounds intriguing however it might be a
better project for filmmaker Tim Burton
to take on the Shadow King it looks like
it's not the first time Disney took on a
darkly themed project only to drop it
out of the blue after all the shadow
king and Mort seem to have met a similar
fate however when it comes to the shadow
king it sieved
say that it was a bigger disappointment
than any other canceled film after all
it dig it's a boot after costing Disney
fifty million dollars to create the
shadow pink was written by Henry Selick
who famously directed the movie Coraline
Disney backed out of the deal when they
determined that the movie would cost too
much to make the shadow King was about a
New York orphan named hat he had long
and strange fingers that derived from a
cruel world
his deprivation often caused him to be
alienated which led him to become lonely
and sad he would soon meet a living
shadow girl who would go on to teach him
that his bizarre fingers cast beautiful
shadows however they could also be used
as shadowy weapons although this movie
is different and entertaining the shadow
monster was terrifying and could
potentially scare children
after all he wanted to beast on a little
boy which is uh absolutely horrifying
knowing this we're not surprised that
Disney opted out the gremlins most of us
are familiar with the movie gremlins
which was released in 1984 however did
you know that Disney once wanted to
release a film with the same name the
gremlins was created by Disney and Roald
Dahl who sought to release the film in
the mid 1940s
despite writing two screenplays and
spending a lot of time and energy on the
project Disney would later cancel it for
a series of reasons first of all the
movie would have been released in close
proximity to the end of World War two
and since the gremlins were fond of
destroying war planes it seemed like too
much of a risk so Disney chalked it up
to bad timing and insensitivity and
ended up putting the movie on the back
burner however its concept was soon
transformed into a storybook which went
on to sell a lot of copies in 2008 Dark
Horse Comics took on the project and
released a comic book miniseries in its
honor so while the gremlins was never
animated by Disney it did see the light
of day keep watching to find out which
Disney movie was written directed and
animated only to be cancelled by the
vice-chairman midway through its
screening king of elves Disney fans
couldn't wait to watch the king of elves
in 2012 sadly its release date Keane and
and Disney had nothing to show for it
since the movie storyline and story book
had been completed many fans asked
themselves why Disney would fold a plug
well as it turns out they had an array
of reasons for scrapping the project the
king of elves was based on philip k dick
short story by the same name it followed
the lives of a troop of elves and a
single dwarf living in Mississippi a
human named Calder would go on to become
their king after saving them from an
evil troll Disney grew nervous as time
went on as they felt like the movie was
far too dark and not merchandise
friendly on top of that frozen was
slated to be released in 2013 which
could halt the movies revenue and since
the project was taking longer to
accomplish their release dates could
have ended up overlapping which simply
wasn't an option in the end producer
Chuck Williams chose to abandon ship to
work on the movie big hero 6 which
proved to be a big success the movie was
officially shelved in 2009 and has yet
to be dusted off and revived although
the movie might have been deemed too
dark for children we can't help but fall
in love with its animation we mean just
look at those elves they're super
adorable wildlife we've kept the best
for last and by best we mean worse
honestly we can't believe that Disney
sought to greenlight this movie seeing
as it was riddled with adult jokes
Wildlife was directed by Howard Baker
and Roger gold it was developed by the
Walt Disney Company
in the late 1990s however it soon got
shelved in 2000 the movie was about a
nightclub owner named red pit sane who
was in dire need of a new star act to
save his club red and kitty start
looking for a brand new act and they
come upon Ella a talking elephant
problem is she has low self-esteem and
is scared to take the stage but all that
changes one night when li gets
electrocuted and awakens to believe
she's a big star the movie seemed like a
whole lot of fun which is why it was
predicted to be a hoot however the
wildlife team embedded some pretty
serious jokes into their film so when
the vice-chairman of the board
Roy Disney viewed the presentation reel
he couldn't believe his ears in fact he
cut the presentation real short claiming
that he was appalled by its sultry humor
so you might be wondering which joke
caused Roy to shut down the product
well apparently Roy's jaw hit the floor
when two characters who were hinted
towards being a part of the LGBTQ
community entered the sewers and said
have you ever been down a manhole before
after hearing this we totally side with
Roy what were the writers thinking we
mean come on that's just ridiculous so
what did you guys think about these
canceled disney movies are there any you
would have liked to see on the big
screen let us know in the comment
section and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up before you go make
sure to subscribe to the things for the
latest Disney news thanks for watching
we'll catch you next time
[Music]